under my Aegis game Abbado palace in
Damascus conquer again today - I need to
accept God's Rakuten adage easy
Moshe calamus M what I stood Shimon
Amina Gaines aye Nintendo switched on
Wii U your game zelda no densetsu
grasshoppers arrived on ok honey she's
your niece Moscow
so today Nemo cargo traffic pass Enda
stop Choa - anna has made Agora in
Telugu atrocity Rocco Nintendo treehouse
remember yogi KOCO Ariana prey is oh yo
it has passed another station an
oceanography core economic dodo euro
scorning Ida's math hello everyone I am
Beltran in Ain a bill Dorf we're here
from Nintendo's treehouse to give the
world its next look at the Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild and we are on a
quest trying to find a shrine a
particular shrine and here we have Kass
and he is a minstrel who travels around
in Hyrule and he's asking if we want to
hear an ancient verse passed down in
this region
yeah and as minstrels or want to do he's
gonna sing to us
fire up the accordion
where the dragon's mouth meets the
Serpent's jaws shrine sleeps in the
forest normal cost okay we got this
that's a Serpent's head right there good
good spotting Nate it seems to be
pointing this way so I'm gonna head over
here it's a nice sunny patch oh don't
let him do that thing in general I think
two-handed weapons like claymores and
axes on no come on yourself together
oh you probably need a snack on
something yeah which is this it's handy
to have snacks so I'm gonna here I'll
eat some hearty fried grains yeah we're
right there right there at the Serpent's
head I bet we go into that cave Oh bill
bill bill bill all right
what them let's pro take over okay I'm
classically trained for this take a
smart here I think charging headlong
into a bunch of guys with electric
arrows it's not it's not the way to go
I'm gonna try to let's let's explore our
stealth option and you're running out of
arrows so you know you were down to two
arrows there you go nice you know I'm
hey buddy else yeah we have this giant
dude right there okay into the mouth as
the Beast you go
this guy seems really big yeah oh so
there was a focus they've got a million
lake powers he was lashing his tongue
out nice Lori rush your sword just broke
[Music]
throw that through that there you go
boom and he's done I mean he looks angry
well you've got with he does use evil
eyes so you're gonna start this guy he's
- he's - what do you got yeah he is you
you're dealing with here eat that one
nope already fine fine you grab his
weapon
Oh your is it wrong to hit him on the
back I don't think it is he's way bigger
than that
yeah my just reward there we go I think
this you can you can see the waiter no
no yeah we need to save a few surprise
it's right there it is right there
there's something awesome right there
mouth but I think we're in it we're
gonna end our shrine quest here I hope
everyone is looking forward to the
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild it'll
be releasing in 2017 on both Wii U and
the all new Nintendo switch hope you're
looking forward to it I sure AM thank
you bye
[Applause]